was brauchen Landwirte von der Politik
um mit dem verschobenen Fokus weg von
Fleisch hin zu pflanzlich basierten
Produkten klarzukommen wir Landwirte
produzieren alles an Lebensmitteln was
der Konsument oder der Verbraucher und
die Bürger kaufen und konsumieren wenn
von jetzt auf gleich keine fleischlichen
Produkte mehr gekauft werden wird sich
da der Markt also auch mir Landwirte uns
umstellen Torben wie kann man dich als
Konsumenten unterstützen das ist eine
relativ einfache Frage wenn man die
heimische Landwirtschaft unterstützen
möchte käuft man am best beim landfür
direkt um die Ecke wenn man im
Supermarkt ist käuft man am besten
Produkte aus Deutschland oder aus Hessen
da gibt's ein hässisches Gütesiegel und
es wäre schon mal Anfang wenn das
argentinische rumstick in den restaurot
von der Speisekarte verschwinden würde
man stattdessen das Stick aus der
heimischen Produktion essen
würde